all right welcome to another edition of
chess openings explained
I'm Jonathan Krantz and today a lot of
people were requesting the French so I
wasn't really going to do the French
tonight because last week we did the
caro-kann and it's you know the pawn
structures can sometimes be a little bit
similar I was thinking maybe I do
something a little bit sharper do some
Sicilian do something else but I noticed
how many people wanted to see the French
and then my dad told me I should cover
the French tonight so so this is for you
dad alright so we'll begin and we'll be
looking at today we're looking at the at
the McCutchin which is a line I'm
surprised a lot of people don't know
about because I was just talking to some
people in the club and it turns out a
lot of people don't even know what this
opening is which means it could be a
really great surprise if your opponent
is not expecting it you can really get
the advantage and it's a long it's sort
of a strategical struggle which when you
play the French typically you're you're
a strategically minded player and that's
the kind of thing you're going for so
we'll jump right into it the French is
defined after just one move after E for
black plays the movie six so similar to
like when we played the Carl cotton with
c6 the point is after white takes the
center because if you can play e4 and d4
you should Blackwell on his second move
strike at the center with the move d5 so
there's a couple moves I can choose from
here there's about four moves that are
played regularly and even a lot of
sidelines already just in this position
white needs to decide what he's going to
do about his epon because it is attacked
so if he does nothing we'll take it so
the most common move is Knight c3 and
we'll be looking at that today the other
popular moves are Knight d2 which is the
tirage there's ie 5 which is the
advanced variation and then there's the
exchange variation but today we're going
to be looking at Knight c3 and here
black has two main choices today we're
going to be looking at night F
which can usually lead to the the
classical lines or it can lead to the
McCutchin which is what we're going to
focus on flex other option is to play
the winter wear which tends to lead to
some sharper positions so if you're an
attacking fighting player and you still
want to play the French these are the
lines youyou probably want to look at
but today we're going to go a little bit
more classical to move Knight f6 and
again there's a another branch in the
theoretical tree there's two popular
moves here we're going to look at the
most popular which is to pin the knight
that's that's one way to deal with the
threat of your epon the reason you
you played the move Knight f6 is to
attack the pond again so once more
you're threatening to win it so white
will usually either push and enforce
your knight back and that's that's a
very decent way to play or he'll pin
your knight and in this position the
most common move if you wanted to play
the classical line is the move Bishop to
e7 which I'll show only briefly mostly
because I have a funny story to tell
white will play the move e5 and after
you go back he has two choices so
there's a lot of choices even in the
opening so the French is really rich in
possibilities in a lot of moves you know
there's several moves you might need to
know if you want to play these lines so
you can even spend kind of a lifetime
just learning the French in the same way
a lot of people spend a lot of time with
different Sicilians I mean there's so
many Sicilians
and equally there's so many French to
you know defense moves so okay the ala
kind Chatard gambit is one possibility
so you're offering a potential pawn to
get some some active play but the
classical line is when white just takes
the bishop and now that the Queen will
take back and on the surface this is
pretty good for white because all of his
pawns are going to end up going to some
dark squares usually in this variation
so that's really good for him and also
this guy is a little bit silly and when
you play the French you might even call
this Bishop the French Bishop because
it's often you know you're bad Bishop
your strategy will revolve around how
can I make my bishop good or something
like that so this looks
pretty appealing for for white and in a
way it is and I know a lot of people
have been put off of playing you know
the French just because of the classical
line they don't really like the
positions that black can get into
they're fine and I play it I played it a
lot myself so it's it's a perfectly fine
way to play but if you're kind of sick
of it
the McCutchin is so it's the way to go
so we got an answer for you and we'll
get to that in a moment but I want to
show this just so I can tell my story
come on in
I've had this position I was playing in
a team tournament so I was playing with
one opponent so I ended up playing lower
rated people because I was on board two
of my two-person team and I played three
1200s in that tournament and I had black
and white against all of them so I had
the white position here and in every
game black made the same exact mistake
so I won three games this way in one
tournament the big mistake is black
plays the move c5 so I'll give the
audience a quick chance here what is the
problem with the move c5 it's already a
blunder yeah why is c5 a mistake that's
that is the question and I'll give you a
hint if you check out these these dark
squares man they're really weak because
the dark squared Bishop swert raided so
white does have a way to exploit the
weak dark squares nothing nothing all
right fine awesome Knight b5 and now you
have two threats the knight is jumping
in on either one of these squares and
it's going to be trouble so I mean you
can Castle and you can give up your rook
or you can allow the check you can play
something like this and you'll get
checked and okay this also is it's not a
lot of fun and we're not going to go too
deep into it I just wanted to mention
that's the alternative to playing the
McCutchin okay so we return to the
Bishop g5 line and now this is the move
that makes it McCutchin Bishop to b4 so
you're pinning this Knight but you may
be wondering if you've never seen this
before
we'll wait a minute white is going to
play the move e5
and my knight is pinned so aren't I
going to lose my knight
so after E 5 you have to play the only
move here for black you have to attack
the piece that's pinning your knight so
h6 is the move and now most people will
treat their bishop the most common that
we're going to look at is Bishop d2 but
it's worth mentioning what happens if
they take the knight on f6 because I
know a lot of I've played a lot of
people even in blitz even you know
people a lot higher rated than me and
they've even played this variation and
it's it's actually okay for for white
but most people won't play it they'd
actually know what they're doing because
they don't like to give up their Bishop
so China is almost in the room here so
what's happening here it looks like it's
it's a really big achievement for for
white but these lines are are kind of
known to be sort of equal ish and I kind
of like playing them as black what what
will end up doing is he's going to play
moves like h4 and Queen h5 and he's
going to try to make sure that it's it's
really hard for you to take this pawn
because I mean this Queen check would it
would kind of embarrass you sometimes
but black will just play Queen to f6
I'll just show this line briefly so this
is the kind of thing that will normally
happen the Queen will eventually get the
pawn back and okay black is going to get
his pieces out and he's going to castle
on the Queen side and if you are to play
this line you do want to keep this dark
squared Bishop on the board he's really
important because you do have some weak
dark squares in your in your camp here
so that's so just one line when she
wanted to touch on that briefly before
we head to the main line which is Bishop
to d2 we will be covering other lines
there's other places to retreat your
Bishop you can go to e3 you can go to c1
but today we're going to focus on the
main line and the purpose of this move
is you're trying to force black to
concede the dark squared bishop so
indeed here you have to do something
your knight is attacked you would like
to jump your knight in to e4 but if you
do this immediately it would be a huge
blunder because what would white play
yeah
Knight takes Knight right so if you take
the knight then you lose your bishop and
if you take the bishop then you're down
to peace he takes back with the knight
not the Queen so that would be a big
mistake so black will first take the
night and again this move the mainline
might surprise you but it's B takes c3
let's look at what happens if we take
with the bishop because some people
might you know want to keep their there
are score Bishop and avoid having the
double pawns but this is nothing special
for white again we're going to jump in
and if they wish to keep their Bishop
they're going to end up playing a move
like Bishop to b4 and the move that
black plays here is c5 so will notice a
couple things either capture doesn't
promise wait anything and in fact if you
take with a pawn this is a big blunder
so we'll see how can a black take
advantage of this move this one is a
little bit tougher
and I'll give you a hint it has to do
with this unprotected bishop okay if
Knight takes e5 it looks like you have a
little trick here right so you're hoping
he takes and you're going to give this
check and then you're hoping that you
get this Bishop back but I'm going to
shock you when I play b4 and then you're
not going to get your piece back so that
is the right idea though we're along the
right lines here we're looking for a
good knight move that does take
advantage of the bishop so we're on the
right track and I'm glad somebody said
that because that does it does seem like
it's a an appealing move in this
position so how else if only we could go
to the other side with the Queen if only
Queen g5 does attack upon now Knight f3
will come with tempo though protecting
the pawn and kicking your queen away and
preventing the trick that you haven't
seen yet mm-hmm have you got it awesome
Knight takes f2 which is a great move
the point is if you take with the king
after this check you're going to lose
your bishop so there's already a little
trick there which is why they'll often
just take with the bishop in this
position and now in this position you
got there bishop back which was the
whole point was to try to keep the
bishop but that doesn't work blacks
gonna play moves like 97 Queen c7 and
he's going to try to get these these
pawns back you can try to hold on to all
of your pawns but it's not going to work
for very long so okay it's hard to
protect all of your pawns now in a
training session for this lecture this
move was suggested but this is a mistake
so let's see if we can figure out white
is trying to pin the knight and then
saying I'll get to keep both of my my
pawns here and I'll be up a pond and you
know I'll play Knight f3 to defend the e
pawn I'll play B forward to defend the C
pawn but black has a really good move
here and it's kind of
same as the trick we just saw so let's
see if we can find this one Queen a5
check and the bishop is lost so okay
there's no way of saving the bishop so
this would be a mistake and I just point
it out because I
somebody tried to play this against me
today and there's a quick reputation
that's the same trick so that's the kind
of tricks you want to be be looking for
as black so now we have an idea of why
in a let's get back to our position here
after we take they're going to take with
the beep on
so our knight is attacked let's remember
so we got to move our knight and we're
going to go into efore and we're hoping
to get their bishop it is possible to
keep this bishop and sacrifice this pawn
this is one line that the white can play
but we're going to focus on the main
move here which is to a force black to
make a decision on the Kings side so the
movie is going to play is Queen to g4
with immediate pressure on the Jeep on
so black has to do something about this
now you can do two things a very popular
move is to move g6 but notice this does
weaken the King side so today we're
going to focus on the move that hasn't
been played in as many games but it is
the the more modern trend it's to avoid
making any weaknesses on your Kings side
because White's trying to play for a
King side attack and you play the move
King f8 defending your pawn so you're
not going to Castle in this game and it
might seem kind of weird ok your rook on
h8 where is he going he's not going
anywhere you know how are you going to
get him out it's going to take some Rema
nuvaring so we're starting to see the
outline of what the plans are going to
be in this position so it's a good time
to take a little pause and try to figure
out what both sides are trying to
accomplish now according to the the pawn
pointing theory white his pawns are all
porting towards the Kings side which
means he has more space on the Kings
side so he's going to play over there
and he's going to try to play for a
checkmating attack black on the other
hand
he's going to be thinking about play on
the queenside
and trying to take advantage of you know
the weak pawn structure over here and
he's going to try to play moves on on
this side of the board so we'll see that
in just a minute so his plans are gonna
be play on the Queen side White's
playing for an attack
the most common move here is Bishop d3
forcing the knight to make a decision
okay we want to take the bishop anyway
so let's take it and now neither side
gets the castle in the mainline here but
okay
we'll see so black wants to play on the
Queen side so the move c5 is the most
popular and White's move here might
surprise you if you've never seen this
before
Knight f3 seems like a good move but
actually the most accurate move here is
h4 you don't really know where this this
Knight is headed sometimes you're going
to want to maneuver your knight all the
way to h5 and there's two paths that you
can take to get there
so you're not really sure where the
Knights going to go also part of whites
attacking plan is he's going to bring
the rook out and over and he's going to
put pressure on some of these pawns
so wherever the rooks going to go he's
playing for an attack right away so he's
got to get his rook into the game so
white will be attacking with four pieces
and some of his pawns over here he's got
the Queen the rook the bishop and the
knight and so he has to try to do that
black on the other hand he's going to
defend and if he defends successfully
then he's going to do well on the Queen
side in the endgame so blacks strategy
is to just know the the attacking plans
by white it's important to familiarize
yourself with White's plans so that you
can defend properly and then in the long
run you're going to have the the better
position going into the endgame because
of some of the weaknesses on the Queen
side so these these pawns here are
pretty tender
so is this isolated pawn and so we'll
check out kind of what's what's going to
happen here c-4 immediately is possible
by black but we're going to look at
games today
by sergei volkov so he's he's one of my
my favorite players just watching his
games and he plays the McCutchin quite a
lot so in the database he's played over
50 games of the McCutchin so if you're
trying to study this I definitely
recommend you look at some of his games
because they're they're very instructive
and he spent a lot of time researching
this so he's already done the hard work
you can just go watch his games and
check out all of his ideas there and
we'll check out one of his games here so
in the first game he's playing a 2100 so
he did pretty well because he's 2600 and
he was close to like 27 that is at his
peak and alright but the next game will
show you opponent that was evenly
matched
so first black will develop his knight
again you can place five first and white
begins the rook maneuver so the rook is
going to go to g3 which will force black
to find some way to defend his Jeep on
all right but first we play the move c5
or c4 sorry and here come the pawns this
is how black is going to get all of his
counterplay it's going to be on the
queenside so he shuts it down he's he's
got a lock down on these ponds and
eventually if he manages the b4 break
he's going to be doing really well white
can actually put this bishop on two
different squares and so this is kind of
our starting point so we're going to
check out from this position White's
ideas in the first game we're going to
put the bishop on e 2 and in our next
game we'll put it on f1 the purpose of
this you know strange retreat is you're
keeping the e2 square open for the night
so the might night might want to use
this square to maneuver around
potentially all the way to h5 so when
you put the bishop on e2 you're not
going to put a night on e to you know
probably the the night is going to end
up going to h3 and you have some options
of the bishop coming to h5 and we'll see
those implications in just a second okay
so black continues with this plan white
doesn't have any serious threats yet
he's going to expand on the Queen side
and so white goes through with his
we plan he puts pressure on g7 so now
black has to defend and okay will defend
with our rook and now what white wants
to do is he wants to get this bishop
into the attack so he's got to move his
Queen out of the way so the only real
square to go to is f4 you can go to f3
but you got to worry that you're
dropping your h1 so ok Queen f4 the
point is you're putting a bishop on h5
and then you're going to have threats on
f7 so I've asked the class if you were
black how would you start to prepare to
defend because that's kind of what's
important here is black you need to know
how you're going to defend the f7 pawn
and so you need to be thinking about it
now in addition to thinking about how
you're getting play on the Queen side so
let's first defend on the King side how
should we do it
reroute this Knight this is a very
common idea
so yeah the knight can go to f5 where it
will be protecting some of the squares
it'll be shielding and that is that is
definitely one thing that happens a lot
in this opening but also the knight is
quite useful over here because it's it's
on some of these squares that you're
trying to push your pawns to who's not
very useful over here on the Queen side
is the bishop so while 97 is definitely
a possible move and like the computer
likes it in like every line it always
plays Knight d7 but most humans play
Bishop to d7 the point is if your F pawn
gets attacked you just drop your Bishop
back and you've got protection so white
should attack and force the bishop back
to e8 and we'll notice black is just
defending over here and he's waiting
he's waiting to win on the Queen side
and it's kind of funny but what black
will often try to do is have a little
Exodus with this King and he'll try to
run all the way to the c7 square that's
kind of the safest square for the King
so it's funny you put it on F 8 and then
you run all the way over to c7
and we'll see that in both of our games
today
that's what you normally want to do when
you're black c7 is the proper square
you're really safe even if you open up
the game eventually with your your break
on b4 your king is still going to be
quite safe on c7 so here comes the night
okay
the night is eventually going to f4
which means White's going to have to
spend another move with his Queen and
okay he's not doing anything to stop
black on the Queen side and in this game
black doesn't do anything to stop before
from coming so black just gets to do it
right away sometimes they try to stop
you they play moves like a3 and rook b1
and they try to stop you in which case
you would have to go a lot slower as
black you know you just have to keep
defending your pawns preparing and it's
it's important to time it right so if
you're playing in a game make sure when
you play before that a your opponent's
not going to somehow get activity from
it it's in it's kind of tough to judge
so it comes with with a lot of
experience the problem with this for
white though sometimes is the pawn on a3
tends to be really weak so so we'll see
what happens here now he's going to move
his Queen so that his knight has the f4
square and he didn't stop black from
playing before so in this game he just
gets to do what he wants it's kind of
nice to see this game because it kind of
shows what happens with both players
just do what they want to do and they
just ignore their opponent as much as
possible so white did all of the moves
he wanted to do on the King side and
black did all the moves he wanted to do
on the Queen side so okay he wanted to
put his knight on f4 so there he goes
and now it begins the King March over to
c7 alright in this move is a bit of a
mistake and you'll know that after he
makes his next move you'll kind of
scratch your head why do you play rook
b1 it seems like a good square but he's
going to move it again on this next move
so black is doing quite well here and in
general if you don't get checkmated or
you know then you're just you're going
to be much better in the ending and
that's what's already happening here
black is has a very nice position he
scoots the rook over and now white moves
his rook again so I guess he was he was
her and it kind of suggests that he
didn't you know know what he was doing
okay
black takes and when white takes back
black now comes up with the plan Queen
to b6 his point is the queen is going to
be for most endings will be favorable
for him especially if the Queen ever
takes the Queen and will look at it and
you take back with you're a pawn this
pawn is going to be on an open file and
so we're going to kind of see this this
theme going on in our game here it is
hard what does white do on the on the
Kings side how is he going to generate
any play well he's got to do something
he's got to come up with some break so
in this game he's thinking f4 f5 but
it's it's very slow Black has already
made great progress on the Queen side so
he's in a lot of trouble so the Queen
was going to be four so there she went
and now it would be a big mistake to to
trade if you were white once again okay
the open file is going to be great for
the black rook and that he's going to be
able to put a lot of pressure on your
weak pawn here so he's unable to trade
and he goes on f4 he's got to go
something like this he's got to generate
some some counter play so he's trying to
do it
black would like to connect his rooks so
he gets his Bishop out of the way a lot
of the times you know this rook will go
somewhere and then he's going to swing
his other rook in to some some square
over here on the Queen side in blue
white thought black had a threat here
and he kind of does he's worried about
the move g6
because if he if we just pass we'll just
we'll just wait a second not make the
best move but alright
you can play move like g6 and when you
move back play h5 and now we shut down
all of the breaks that you have on the
Queen on the King side you're going to
have to like Riemann over your rook and
then you're gonna have to push g4 is
going to take a lot of time and black is
still making a lot of progress on the
Queen side so afraid of that
he brought his Bishop back so he can
meet g6 you know getting ready to play
h5 with the move
h5 himself so
okay black didn't play necessarily the
best move here but this move is fine and
white should realize he's worse here and
he should just trade these these rooks
so he's a lot worse so he should trade
things instead he keeps the pieces on
the board and so it's kind of like white
is playing for a win okay this makes
some sense look at how how weak those
pawns over there so why it is doing
something but black is a lot faster so
alright a good move the knight is
getting ready to jump into beef b5 the
bishop has the a four square so a very
good plan for for black here okay let's
see and now this move was another
mistake I don't think that white saw
what blacks next move was so I'll let
the audience try to come up with what
was played here because he was probably
expecting maybe he'll trade Queens maybe
he'll retreat the Queen somewhere but
black didn't do that and we kind of
talked about when white plays a3 that
that pawn is weak so I'll give you guys
just a second to try to come up with
what the plan is here and it's not a
brilliant move it's not like a wild
tactic it's just just a good solid move
okay he kept the Queen on the board
Queen a4 so the knight is coming in to
b5 which is going to you know have a lot
of pressure over here so a3 was a big
mistake
and I guess he didn't realize just how
bad it was so he's got to get on with
his play here and after Knight B five
white blunders and this is the big
mistake to cost him the game even though
it seems like a normal move he plays
Queen e3 he gets the Queen out of the
way but it's actually a blunder that's
going to lose the game the right move
here is really hard to find so I'll give
the people at home here just a second
see if you guys can configure it out you
can pause the video to if you want to
try to figure out how white can take
care of this because he's in a lot of
trouble you know how do we what's going
on our queen is attacked but
but okay here it is I'll reveal the
answer he can play the move rook to b1
and what will still be worse than this
line but it's his best try to save his
game so just you're saying okay well
okay I take your queen right now white
will insert to move f6 the point is the
King has to go to the back rank and now
the rooks are no longer connected so I
can safely take the rook so you're going
to get some pieces you're going to get a
rook and a knight for the Queen but
blacks position is quite enviable here
okay so why it's going to take some of
this some of these pawns but okay at
some point he's going to play the move
King c7 he's going to kick your rook
away and black will still be better here
but this was White's best try instead in
the game we saw Queen to e3 so now we
just take the pawn we just take on the
pond and we're attacking c2 so white has
to do something about that so you don't
have time to like pin the night and try
to win it because okay there's gonna be
checks coming here so he first gives the
check and then he has to protect his
pawn so we all welcome Danny Machuca to
the audience are all star now we're
getting serious all right so he comes up
with a nice way to attack the pond again
and now his rook is infiltrating so his
plan on the the Queen side has been a
real success here he's able to get all
of his pieces in and you're when the C
pawn falls you know your whole Queen
side is collapsing and okay we got this
past pawn when we take your seat pawn
we're going to have to pass pawns White
is in a lot of trouble alright he tries
to defend and now black missed a tactic
and we have a brilliant tactician in the
audience who can maybe find this move
right awesome yeah so the point is you
can take here with Knight b1 forking the
the king and queen so this tactic was
missed and it was missed twice two moves
in a row so okay even though even the
best missed some good tactics
instead Queen before was played
obviously this is a good move to white
doesn't really want to trade and help
connect your pawns but okay he takes one
of the pawns
so again rook c2 is best with this this
little tactic but it was it was missed
okay so instead Bishop to a4 like how
many times can you attack the same pond
so he's using all of his pieces now and
all right you're just you're in a lot of
trouble he trades Queens it's not going
to help them you're still dropping your
pawn all you can do is prepare for the
pond to be gone and all right things are
things aren't really falling apart it's
not pretty here and these guys are
looking really good so he he pushes his
C pawn now is his Bishop is getting
ready to come back and pin the night and
it's basically over here white tries to
get some counter play he has this is his
target but black is just too fast now
okay pins the night you all right now
you can just take here if you want but
but what's the point of allowing any
counter play so he plays rook f8 now
you're not attacking here White has some
plans of keeping attacking the pawn but
it's not gonna be fast enough okay so he
gets out of the pin but now we can take
your knight and remove the defender of
d4 so that was played and all of a
sudden black now has three passed pawns
and the bishop is attacked so it's going
to go somewhere where it attacks this
pawn and you know you could eat
obviously easily just defend it and
you'll win but the move c2 just ends the
game right away and white resigned here
the thread over up to b1 is just too
strong and you're going to lose a lot of
material and the game is over
so that was a good example of what
happens when both players play what they
want to play white played for just a
King side attack ignored everything that
black wanted to do black defended
properly he understood all of the
attacks that white was going to come up
with and then his Queen side advance won
the day for him okay
so we'll look at one more game here bye
bye Sergei and this game is against
somebody much higher rated so they were
almost the same rating at the when they
played this game and we'll check it out
so we'll go back to our position right
the McCutchen so they they attack our
night we have to attack the piece that's
pending us they retreat we have to take
their their knight first and then we hop
in queen g4 forces us to either play g6
or King f8 king of âge is what we're
looking at today I force us to take the
bishop we're happy to do so we get to
play c5 and here we go we'll notice we
get back to this position now in the
last game the Bishop went to e2 which is
of course a good move but now we're
going to look at the the different move
here Bishop to f1 which we mentioned was
possible the point is e 2 is available
for the night ok so and I like what
black decides to do here he protects his
stuff in advance
we know that the rook is is probably
going to g3 we understand ok the night
is coming in and he prepares to
immediately run his King over to the
square we know we want to go to c7 and
he does it as early as possible in this
game you don't have to do this you can
of course play you know just moves back
b5 a5
you can do these sorts of plans but in
this game he's prepared for a mass
exodus of a king and he's not joking he
just goes for it the king is running to
c7
alright we know the night is coming in
and now black kind of has a little
problem ok this is going to go here and
put some pressure on our Jeep on we
understand that but he's prevented us
from playing the move King d7 which is
what we were trying to play because if
we played King g7 what would white play
here Knight takes d5 exploiting the pin
so notice it won't let me take the
knight because of the pin here so he had
to come up with a way how can I you know
get my king over to the
I'm trying to go to and also deal with
the fact that my G pond is about to be
attacked you played Queen to f8 which
protects the Jeep on in advance and now
the king has a safe route over to the c7
square okay
now the night isn't on e to make sense
for the bishop to be there and the King
keeps going we know where he's going
white plays all the moves where we're
expecting and I in a minute here we're
going to get our King to c7 alright this
is a useful move sometimes he's going to
go here also nice for us one of the
things with the Queen on f8 that we
should should mention here is she'll
often be able to go all the way to the
a3 square which will prevent white from
ever playing a3 himself or a4 trying to
prevent our Queen side counter play and
we'll see that soon all right Queen f4 a
very typical move the King gets to worry
where he wants to go and now this is the
plan by white he's got to do something
over here so in the last game we saw
somebody go f4 f5 here white begins with
g4 so we'll we'll take a good look at
this this pawn advance and now that gets
to play the move that he wants to play
here so he gets to play his Queen to a3
preventing white from moving his a pawn
and now this this rook is stuck
passively defending the pawn what
happens if we take this pawn there's a
tactic here for black awesome right so
there's the pins all over the place in
this opening and this is a sacrifice you
always want to be looking for when
you're black the knight will often
sacrifice itself for for one of the
pawns here so in this case Knight takes
d4 would be good the point is you can't
take because then you're dropping your
rook all right yeah so I mean there's
there's some pretty rich possibilities
here we need three those a sensible move
now the rook is protected so these
sacrifices won't work
also the Queen is protecting the d4
square taking away any potential
tactical possibilities so black gets on
with it b5 at the right moment he's
going to play b4 he'll proud
prepare it and here he comes okay so
he's he's trying to get some some play
over here he has to find some way to
open up the kingside otherwise he's
going to have no play in this game
so black just calmly prepares he might
consider in the future to move like a
five then you'll play B for it at just
the right moment and let's see what what
White's going to do what is this rip
going to do maybe it'll come here maybe
it'll go here and support the F pawn
push which it will because I know the
game okay
so black gets on with it and white comes
up with his plan he's going to play f5
he's going to have you know with the
rook on the F file he'll be able to at
some point take here and the rook will
have the open file and that was the time
so b5 was played so white gets on with
it so both people are doing what they're
trying to be doing and here black makes
a really strange move flex position is
quite good here he's a lot better and
then he makes this this really strange
move Queen to b2 which throws away his
entire advantage okay white now just
kicks the Queen back and that was kind
of a waste to turn now white gets to do
something he wants to do so he just
reroutes the knight he's putting some
pressure here on e6 at some point he'll
he'll take obviously we're never going
to take here because then our D pawn is
going to be too weak
so okay g5 and it's it's funny I've seen
it it only seems to be in his games I've
seen a lot of games with the McCutcheon
and I noticed Volkov
he plays g5 and a lot of them it's a
good way for black to stop a lot of the
the counter play on the King side and
it's kind of unusual normally you don't
want to push your pawns on the Kings
side because that's where your opponent
is attacking but here it does really
limit what white is able to do so after
he takes on passant we take back all
right it's kind of nice that the pawns
here on this side are are nice and
symmetrical so if they ever push upon
either way we can always meet it with
advancing the other pawn so that's
that's a possibility which is kind of
nice positional e4 black all right
and I assume white says okay I'm a
little bit worse here so I'm going to
try to trade the Queen's
so he allowed that to happen
we can take our pawn back but he first
inserts the move g5 like and take her or
just move this Knight and that will take
back the pawn and if white does nothing
we're going to play rook to a8 and then
we're going to target this guy and we're
going to bring our rook into a3 which
will be a good Square for the rook
okay our rook is attacked so we'll move
it and that white tries to rid himself
with the weakness he plays the move a3
which is kind of what you want to do you
got to get rid of the weakness but it
also allows black to get a passed pawn
here so black pushes and now he's going
to make a passer white can take once and
will this guy be strong or will he be
weak well he's looking pretty good right
now we're only two squares away so we'll
see what a white comes up with you can
take first and now here he comes with
this rook so he's getting ready to play
rook h7 and I exploit this he'll make a
pin here and he'll try to win this
bishop now whenever black can push his
uh his passed pawns he should do it
so he pushes right away and now his his
rook is at you know stuck here stuck on
the B file he's got to prevent that that
guy from coming and okay but now black
is infiltrating black is a lot faster
here so he played back if you defend
with your bishop here actually black has
a really good plan he's a little bit
faster he can just go win this pawn in
the time it takes you to go win my
bishop and I'll go somewhere I'm ready
to take your Bishop and I'm ready to
play a move like rook a 1 so this would
actually be quite good for black so I
guess he saw that neither side just put
his King on D - obviously that hangs the
D pawn so we should grab it and now we
have to pass pawns
all right so things are looking good he
attacks our rook and whenever he pins us
we'll just defend our bishop
okay but weight also has some counter
place so we do have to be really careful
you're better is black but it's still
really complicated and sharp he's going
to take try to attack our pawn here and
here black decided to go for for a kind
of cool little tactic he just brought
his King back and now after he takes who
could find this tactical move what was
blacks idea
yeah Bishop a4 was his idea the point
being if you take now there's a fork
we're going to attack your king in your
rook and we're going to win material
also it gives them a chance to get rid
of the delight squared Bishop so okay
the route gets out of the way we get to
chop off the bishop and now we just need
to find a way to make use of this this
really nice pass pawn so okay this move
is good there's also there's some other
moves but this move is good enough now
we have to pass pawns
so when you can push your passport
white doesn't have time now to take this
pawn because what will we play here our
main choices are pushing or taking the
rook
okay so d3 I can just put it on the
board that's what you're saying
okay okay this is fine so right we
gained a tempo on the King and okay if
you try to protect your rook you can
lose your rook and stop me from queening
immediately but uh if you go anywhere
and protect your rook I'm going to take
it and I'm too fast
you can go back and sacrifice your rook
but not really because I'm gonna block
with my knight so okay so d4 here is a
nice move not giving wait a chance to
take his very strong beep on all right
so he goes back to defend and when we
can push our passed pawns we should do
it so there we go again
the King comes up well we can push our
past pawns we should do it so he pushes
this passed pawn and we're we're getting
ready so he is he's blockading with his
two rooks and here black missed the best
move
he took the pawn but there's even better
because white is hoping he gets to take
you know some of our pawns here if
you're white you're thinking man maybe I
can just get one of these guys off the
board life will be easier then I can
focus on on getting the other guy and we
got to make sure we don't lose these
guys or suddenly it's the tables have
turned
the best move here night.they we're usin
95 was played in the game 91 is actually
a stronger move this prevents both
captures of your pawns here so if you
take this one then we'll give this check
and we're rallies winning your work here
also it should we mentioned you can't
take this guy because of this move so
either way we're winning your rooks you
can't take I'm taking the pawn is a good
move it just wasn't the the best so
welcome people just keep coming in very
popular class so alright he ended up
taking one of the ponds which is good
for him but he's in kind of a lot of
trouble here so we can remove one rook
and okay this guy is is quite strong
it's hard to move your night because of
this pawn and okay so he gives this
check he can win another pawn he's gotta
move his rook and he trades into a
winning ending soon white accepts that
he needs to lose an exchange here so he
he gives up his rookie allows this this
fork just to pick up that pawn he was
too dangerous and this is actually a
winning endgame for black it's a it's
going to be tough you know but a good
strong Grandmaster should be able to win
this pretty easily so he's just going to
gonna pick up some stuff you don't want
to drop your pawn I'm so he searched
this check and then the last the last
trick here the white has up his sleeve
he in this position pushes his pawn so
my my last question is what happens if
we take this pawn what was White's
drawing idea
this was why tried his last little trick
here yeah excellent work Knight to c5
how do you defend this pawn so you move
your rook somewhere if we can take the
pawn king of rook versus King and Knight
is going to be a theoretical draw but uh
okay black was on to it he just improved
his King and then white gave it up so
he's going to collect the pawn and rook
with and upon is going to be a win for
black and okay he's he's a strong
Grandmaster so they both were so they
they resigned here so hopefully that
gives you kind of a unique move that you
can play in the French maybe you haven't
thought about playing the McCutchin or
maybe you have for a while and you just
you wanted to see some of the ideas here
so I'd encourage everybody to to go and
try it try them a cut shin please like
subscribe do Internet stuff and keep
sending in your requests for openings
maybe I'll pick yours next week thank
you